a new book details the dramatic effects
that digital devices can have on today's
tech-savvy kids it's called a Gen Y
today's super connected kids are growing
up less rebellious more tolerant less
happy and completely unprepared for
adulthood and what that means for the
rest of us oh boy lots of work author
and psychologist Jean twangy coin the
term ijen for kids who were born between
1995 and 2012 this is the first
generation to spend their entire
childhoods with smartphones and social
media twanging reveals they're getting
less sleep postponing sex and even
delaying gasp getting a driver's license
the book is published by atria that's an
imprint of Simon & Schuster which by the
way is a division of CBS and Jean joins
us at the table Oh Jane hello we all
sort of are clutching our pearls about
they're delaying their driver's license
because didn't we guys when you turn 16
so so wanted freedom yeah it was the
first thing you want to do was go to the
DMV but you said they'd delay the
driver's license they don't get a summer
job they're delaying sex they're hanging
out with their parents what is happening
with this group yeah so it's so common
for people to say oh you know kids are
growing up so quickly these days you say
growing slowly but they're growing up
more slowly so with teens so 18 year
olds now look like 15 year olds used to
in terms of the things you mentioned
like getting a job and driving do they
act like 15 year olds 18 well in some
ways they do it just haven't had as much
independent experience but yeah the
driving one really struck me - there was
one young man who told me well I didn't
get my driver's license because my
parents didn't push me to get my license
which to a gen Xer like me wait what are
you talking about it's the other way
around that it's the kid pushing the
parent so is it is it smartphones the
calls or something else so with this
trend of growing up slowly there's a
bunch of causes going on it's a really
broad cultural trend with drinking
alcohol less and not getting a job and
not dating as much not having sex during
high school its overall development has
just slowed down that teens are just
taking longer so the Y question is
always a little hard to answer with this
but it's probably at least partially
because people have smaller family
they expect their kids to go to college
they nurture them more carefully and
then these trends started to accelerate
with the smartphone's a lot of them have
to do it getting out of the house and
when you're talking to your friends all
the time when the party's on snapchat
you don't have to drive as much or go
out without your parents as much I
thought this was fascinating you write
of the eye Jen's mental health quote
there's not a single exception all
screen activities are linked to less
happiness and all non screen activities
are linked to more happiness that's the
research yeah so if you look at these
big national surveys of teens that ask
them what they do with their time so
things like homework sports reading
getting together with their friends all
of those non screen things they're all
correlated with greater happiness and
you think about anything that's done
with a screen texting social media TV
online peer games all of those are
correlated with lower happiness you
talked to so many i Jen's all around the
country and one of the reasons you say
it's important to do that is to talk to
this group at the same age so you get it
from them rather than older people
comparing what they're going through
right what was your overall takeaway
when you talk to the different groups
and compare them to the Millennials yeah
so I do from survey data on an 11
million young people that's been
collected since the 60s and 70s then
about 200 in-depth surveys and then
about 25 who are interviewed in depth
and really I think the the smartphone is
one of the keys in explaining why they
are so different from Millennials so for
example that their mental health has
really trended downward starting around
2012 should they have smartphones well
that's the question right so if you look
at that link between smartphones and
unhappiness
our suicide risk factors or depression
what they suggest is doesn't really harm
him to spend say up to an hour even an
hour and a half a day with a screen but
two hours and beyond that's when you
start to see the link to these mental
health issues that's interesting yeah
thank you so much yeah
but in one quick question guys how did
you your mom you how did you change your
own behavior with your kids yeah so the
day I analyze that data looking at
screen time and unhappiness and
depression I took my kids tablets and
put them in a drawer so there's a lot of
flip phones at your house I don't like
you
yeah real is is really important thank
you so much thank you very much Jean
Twenge
her name the name of the book rather i
gen it goes on sale next tuesday that's
August 22nd wherever you like to buy
your books